now hit the mainstream with new
technologies support from across the
political spectrum and advocates from
Stephen Hawking to Mark Zuckerberg it's
no surprise that people have begun to
take the prospect seriously so for
tonight's head-to-head or today's
head-to-head we're asking universal
basic income is it time we've got two
fantastic speakers on my right is guy
standing who has written widely on areas
of labor economics labor market policy
unemployment labor market flexibility
structural adjustment policies and
social protection he is the world's
leading authority on universe or basic
income on my left is Deirdre McCloskey
acclaimed libertarian author and
historian in 2013 she received the
Julian L Simon Memorial Award from the
Competitive Enterprise Institute for her
work examining factors in history that
led to the advancement in human
achievement and prosperity so I'd like
to ask a guy standing to open tonight
today's debate well thank you very much
I've been working on basic income for
over 30 years and for many of those
years I was regarded as mad bad and
dangerous to know and as Peter has just
said suddenly I'm becoming respectable
I'm becoming very worried about this
because I've never wanted to mix with
the company that many of those who are
coming out in favor but I think it's
indicative of a perfect storm of factors
that are precipitating basic income to
the middle of our political discourse
and before I say what that perfect storm
is let me just make it clear to those of
you are not familiar with the debates
but what we mean by a basic income is
that every man and every woman and every
child at a lower level would receive a
regular payment from the state in money
form with no conditions no behavioral
conditions you don't have to do this so
that till that to prove something you
get it as an economic right
and it would be none withdrawable it
would be a permanent citizenship right
or a legal resident right we can come
back to the issue of defining what we
mean by universalism but the essence of
it is that everybody would have basic
Income Security
now you can have a very low level and
you can raise it or you can have a
higher level etc that is a separate
issue but the important thing is to
realize that the reason someone like
myself supports moves towards so having
a basic income for all of us is
fundamentally ethical not economic it's
ethical first of all because it's a
matter of social justice
I strongly resent the title of our
session money for nothing a lot of
wealthy people in this country get a lot
of money for nothing and I will I resent
it because if you go back to the history
of the discourse around basic income and
you go back to the charter of the forest
in 1217 and through Thomas Paine and so
on essentially what we're saying is that
the wealth of all of us the income of
all of us is far more to do with the
efforts and achievements of many in
generations before us and if you accept
private inheritance of wealth something
for nothing if you notice then we should
have a sense of a social dividend on the
collective wealth because we don't know
whose ancestors produced the wealth
maybe yours maybe yours maybe mine I
don't know we don't know and in that
sense we need to give a social justice
orientation for it now if you are
religious I'm not religious but if you
are and many people have come at it from
a religious point of view you can say
that God has given us unequal talents
and in a sense a basic income would be a
compensation to those who don't for one
reason or another have the same talents
as ever you can also approach it as a
matter of ecological justice one minute
so for me
the Justus orientation of a basic income
is fundamental
the second ethical reason is it would
enhance freedom it would enhance freedom
in the libertarian sense it would
enhance freedom in the nineteenth
century liberal sense in the sense of
avoiding a paternalistic state classic
statement from th Greene is you can only
be moral if you're in a position to be
moral and it's also better of freedom
from a Republican freedom tradition it's
a sense of giving people even a small
amount the ability to say no and the
ability to feel that you are not subject
to power that's unaccountable and the
third reason and then I'll stop but I
think this is fundamental is that almost
by definition a basic income would give
people basic security we are facing a
plague of insecurity and the
psychologists have taught us that too
insecure people have a suffering of a
lower IQ a smaller mental bandwidth they
cannot behave rationally because they
are under stress and that's a reality
security is a human need and a basic
income would move us in that direction
before we go any further it's not a
panacea it has to be seen as a 21st
century part of a progressive politics
and that is the argument that I advanced
in the book and I hope we will discuss
it around that thank you
well this was stages as a debate because
the organizers think of me as a
conservative I think they think I'm a
Tory or something and and actually I'm a
I'm a to use this word I don't like much
I'm I'm a libertarian but I'm a
bleeding-heart libertarian I am a
Christian I'm an Anglican the Archbishop
of Canterbury is not first in my
thoughts but I think he's very nice and
and so I'm I'm I'm I'm a liberal I'm a
19th century liberal but I would call it
a a party or a view that wants to treat
everyone like adults wants to be fair
and I certainly strongly agree with with
guy's point that an unconditional
subsidy to people without conditions you
you can't drink
look most of you are drinking here you
can't you can't be gay you can't be this
you can't be that I of course don't want
that and that that's a very attractive
part of this this this way of thinking
and indeed it's been an attractive part
for a long time among economists the
1950s James Tobin mildly on the Left
Keynesian at Yale and Milton Friedman
former colleague of mine at the
University of Chicago both proposed a
what they what Milton called the
negative income tax to give exactly such
a supplement to the poor with the
proviso that we drop all the conditional
grants
we still we stop trying to push people
around in a way that's the basic liberal
idea and historically speaking it's very
strange
it's an 18th century conviction among a
bunch of intellectuals Mary
Wollstonecraft and Voltaire and and it
it's say so it's it's it's the idea that
the liberal idea is that you ought to
treat people with respect as adults and
let them make their own lives and as a
Christian is this bleeding-heart part
I'm very willing to help them on their
own terms not on mine I don't insist
that they pledge allegiance to the
Chicago School of Economics or something
like that but my my worries about it is
that I don't think Universal makes a lot
of sense and you can you you can see the
problems here's one ethically and
philosophically why not a world
universal income what's this about the
British or the Americans why should
people or Swiss why should people
defined by a certain national border be
the ones that get the subsidy motivate
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you